alright so when i subtract if i do to
take away one what are we getting right
so on the left-hand side i've got this
and on the right-hand side I have this
side okay yeah now in some ways I'm
going to be very similar things on the
right hand side I can just factor eyes
now look carefully at the left hand side
what does that difference in its rules
correspond to hear when you end up with
hello this is up sa2 that's this
distance right let me draw
there's dissension right and while i'm
subtracting from it is sa1 hmm what are
you not getting okay now i'm going to do
that same to be across thing taking
advantage of the symmetry of the ellipse
right I'm going to put this across this
whole distance here what is this mission
by the way the one I'm rubbing off here
to a right I want to put it over this
side so whatever what is I really should
have them in different colors actually
that means i have got that log into all
that that represents si tu and i'm
subtracting that interval you see that
so because i'm subtracting this progress
this part just goes so now I've got
double of double of what OS you see that
and you see y OS is kind of valuable to
me right so i'm going to write 20 s over
here on the left-hand side visual on it
hey look at this guy what did you make
an appt a 2n 82 and where z hn take away
one in what is that this is easier isn't
it yeah yeah you're taking away that gap
before you get left with is the major
axis which is 28 all right so I've got
eight times two hey sorry
okay i'm almost there right i just have
to divide by 2 which gives me this
enough of it actually doesn't know so
what does this tell me what is this
imply this tells me where the focus is
right because s is where the focus is I
know the distance from the origin to the
focus and I'm just on the axis the x
axis so the horizontal distance tells me
this is a collar 0 which tells me where
they are the focuses namely at minus a
comma 0 is that make sense and you with
me so far okay right so therefore
coordinates are folk i ah
plus or minus AE comma 0 z XX assuming
of course with like center of the origin
obviously we were shipped off somewhere
else on the equations we have to do as
corresponding translations well that's
why would do with that case okay now we
are still not okay it breaks my heart
I'm gonna have to up the racism son
second so I keep this working this is
not enough this looks great but it's not
wonderful what was the original question
I'm trying to terrify me of the original
question haha yeah I've got these guys
right and I'm trying to find out where
are these and these that's what I was
after okay now I've got no a long way
forward i I've worked out an equation
and coordinates for these what I'm stuck
because I don't know what it is I know
what they are but I don't know what is
okay now the very fact that look at your
arm look up according to the phone hi
and the equations of the directory
scooters you should have nothing to do
it be do you notice that right we have
not used be at all that's a clue to us
that using be is going to be our kind of
access into working out what the
eccentricities and that kind of makes
sense right like that squeezy squashy
thing that's what the ratio tells us has
to do with how far gone this way how far
I've got this way all right so here's my
challenge to you so it get started
before i show you your book um since you
now know
the coordinates of the phone line any
equation of the directions you'll back
to where we started in period 0 you can
use those to get equation of the lockers
right you can use those to get that
right remember because we've got our a
distance between two points and then
you've got a perpendicular distance you
just need to know the coordinates of the
point and the equation of a line which
you know we just established and you
should be able to write here right can
you do a couple give it a shot